il ya 20 ans l'euro arrivé dans nos
porte-monnaie mais à côté de cette
devise officielle d'autres fleurissent
un peu partout depuis quelques années
des monnaies locales qui circulent à
l'échelle d'une ville ou d'une région
cela n'a rien d'illégal bien au
contraire c'est autorisé par la loi
depuis 2014 en france il existe 80 de
monnaies locales
4 en bourgogne franche comté on vous
fait découvrir la toute dernière la
chouette qui circule depuis un an dans
la métropole dijonnaise mais encore dans
une grande discrétion
[Musique]
à l'ombre de notre dame et de son
célèbre volatiles on peut désormais
toucher d'autres chouette c'est le nom
de ses billets
vous savez tous que c'est absolument pas
les connais pas ces menées localement
david a
joli graphisme
s'est pas réduit
en fait c'est la monnaie dijonnaise
complémentaire à l'euro sans ces
véhicules et plus de valeur que sa
simple valeur faciale une petite
révolution dont pour l'heure peu de
dijonnais ont eu vent
[Applaudissements]
ces jours de course pour pierre
depuis quelques mois le roe cohabite
avec la chouette dans son portefeuille
ce dijonnais a adhéré à l'association
qui les aimait pierre pay ainsi 50 à 60%
de ses emplettes alimentaires dans des
commerces qui acceptent ces coupures ça
nous fait 14h42
super 14 et puis je vais vous donner les
42 centimes d'euro de huy parfait la
chouette monnaie voilà s'il ya 4,4
valeur faciale
25 10 4 et 1 une chouette égal 1 euros
comme pierre 140 dijonnais ont été
séduits par cette monnaie locale pour
régler certains de leurs achats je vais
dans un comptoir de change une fois par
mois au début du mois et puis je change
de 150 ou 300 chouette et ça me
permettra d'aller voir l'un des 23
commerçants qui acceptent le règlement
en chouette la raison d'être de la
chouette et de circuler pour dynamiser
l'économie locale
impossible de l'épargné sur un compte ou
de spéculer sur son cours pensez
l'argent autrement en y injectant plus
d'éthique c'est ce qui a convaincu
pierre de rejoindre l'aventuré
on essaye de vivre un petit peu
autrement et de faire attention et
justement de favoriser les circuits
courts on ne veut pas que ça brasse et
pique sa phase d des fluctuations
monétaires enfin que ça voilà qu
on essaye de garder l'environnement et
ont souvenir emploie
aujourd'hui
97% des échanges monétaires ce fonds sur
les marchés financiers
bien loin de l'économie réelle avec tous
les risques de krach boursier qui
viennent régulièrement ébranlé les états
et leurs populations
à contre-courant les monnaies locales
ancré n'a rien d'illégal s'est même
inscrit dans la loi depuis 2014 seule
condition que l'équivalent en euros de
ce qui circule dans la ville soient
déposés sur un compte bancaire bloquée
pour rembourser les porteurs si
d'aventuré la monnaie disparaissait
réussite la plus éclatante le choc haut
à bayonne
quatre mille personnes utilisent ces
billets chez 1200 professionnels et
auprès de 33 méric 3 millions de chevaux
circulent
à dijon les débuts sont plus modestes
11000 chouette l'équivalent de onze
mille euros ont été émises depuis le
lancement de la monnaie en mars 2021
c'est une association et sa poignée de
bénévoles qui ont créé la chouette ce
jour là deux d'entre eux jacques iv
nicolas s'apprête à faire naître de nous
elle coupure à l'aide de ses pinces à
gaufrage l'une des cinq clés de sécurité
protégeant la chouette des contrefaçons
la dernière étape avant la mise en
circulation des billets ça coûte 50
euros ça au lieu des 500 euros de de
bouffe rage par l'imprimeur preuve que
tout est locale on commence à devenir
complètement tributaire des banques avec
le paiement sans contact avec le
paiement sur smartphone c'est des
technologies qui rentre dans la vie des
gens je suis quelqu'un qui veut de la
liberté je ne veux pas qu'on suive je ne
veux pas qu'on sache ce que je fais je
ne veux pas qu'on sache ce que je pense
donc je suis dans la monnaie locale pour
garantir ma liberté celle des autres
retour à l'épicerie de julie relocaliser
son alimentation au plus près des
producteurs la rendre plus respectueuse
de l'environnement grâce au vrac c'est
le credo de cette commerçante des idéaux
qu'elle partage avec la monnaie locale
elle ne pouvait donc qu'adhérer à la
chouette chaque semaine dans sa boutique
cinq à dix clients choisissent ce mode
de paiement c'est encore peu et ce n'est
pas là la seule difficulté julie a de la
trésorerie qui dort dans sa caisse des
chouettes qu'elle ne parvient pas encore
à écouler l'idée c'est d'avoir une
chaîne continue et qu'ils aient jamais
un cul de sac avec quelqu'un qui se
retrouvent avec des choix qui donc ne
peut rien faire on peut en faire deux
choses soit on peut se rémunérer avec
donc je mènerai une partie de notre
salaire avec des chouettes ou aussi
payer des factures de fournisseurs
locaux avec aujourd'hui vu qu'on en est
au début il ya encore assez peu de
producteurs qui font partie de la
chouette donc quand ce sera plus évolué
on va pouvoir plus facilement les faire
circuler
et pour que la chouette passe de main en
main il faut porter la bonne parole
auprès des particuliers mais aussi des
professionnels pour agrandir le réseau
angèle et nicolas ont pour mission d'
approcher les commerçants ils ne les
choisissent pas par hasard mais sur une
éthique commune et avec cette
restauratrice ces bénévoles semble avoir
vu juste l'écouté plus que simplement
poli nous on est dans une démarche déjà
à la base 100 % français mais on aime
notre région on essaye d'être plus local
possible et
et une monnaie locale c'est génial ça
permet pas justement si plusieurs
commerçants adhèrent à sa justement de
découvrir d'autres commerces de
travailler ensemble c'est aussi ça une
monnaie locale créer du lien sur un
territoire mais cela demande aussi de
changer ses habitudes dans une économie
à la consommation toujours plus
numérique où l'argent est toujours plus
dématérialisé ces bénévoles en sont bien
conscients mais pas de quoi les
décourager
en tant que professionnels adhérents
partenaires proba il ya peu de gens qui
vont venir consommer en chouette donc
des fois il se pose la question
d'adhérer et en tant que particulier
c'est la même chose il ya peu d'endroits
où on peut dépenser c'est chouette donc
dans les deux cas ce qu'on leur dit
c'est que c'est aussi un acte militant
et pour démarrer on a besoin de
militants vous vous y croyez ou gèle
totalement totalement ce que c'est dans
ma façon de penser ma façon de consommer
j'apprécie
mon produits locaux le savoir faire
mettre en avant une culture un
territoire un terroir et
et oui c'est c'est mon moteur
en france 80 de monnaies locales ont vu
le jour ces dix dernières années avec
des fortunes diverses
le chemin est encore long pour que la
chouette s'implante à dijon mais qui
sait peut-être que petit à petit
l'oiseau fera son nez